oh hey how's it going everyone
look behind YouTube's most fashionable
show where we review PewDiePie memes
that's right everybody the greatest
memes of all time who made it to the
ultimate glory of eternal life by
submitting their mean to meme appeal
news what helped me it's all the same
it's all the same anyway no one really
cares let's review the first PewDiePie
meme everybody leave your entries
already closed if oil is made from
decomposed dinosaurs and plastic is made
from oil plastic dinosaurs are made from
real dinosaurs wait a minute oh ok ok
son dad why is my sister's name one
piece oh it's another one of those
because it's your mother's biggest dream
thanks dad no problem
7 votes you guys suppose the worst means
I have ever seen how am I supposed to
laugh at this do you want anything
positive for me to say about this is
garbage it's pathetic unless this has
7up votes the doors return mean
correction do it right go to your room I
could save your life but imma get it
packaged you can get a doctor and a
wristband the patient is laughing with
the doctor he wants to die who doesn't
oh my god yes I love this sketch I slap
everything this is the first time I've
seen a decent version of this me
Wow card says men's shirts slap Ramada
roof some vehicles this is the only car
slapped me my actually thought was kind
of funny just because I like the
original video is this me you guys are
learning I am actually quite proud every
meme after 10 minute mark is about know
all right wait we got a new the why
intro hey I don't know how that works
but that's pretty cool PewDiePie leaked
analytics oh my god I thought it was
real your estimated revenue 0 for is
real and Israel everybody thank you
thank you
it sure is wonderful to entertain
millions of people that's right I am
entertaining with my own original
content and I get so much back you know
I don't need the money I get so much
back from you guys that's really all I
need to thrive that's really all I need
to live please just more comments
telling me what a piece of garbage I am
what the hell was that this is so sad
Alexa play this mercy go to playing
espacio - I like how some memes just
keep lingering forever they just never
die that's how you know it's a good mean
the older subscribers of Peter pie well
are they still subscribed though SP RVD
Ajax the beasts Tex cakti and artha a
dude
I remember having 19 subscribers and I
was so happy I was so happy what a
wholesome moment I was wondering how
many on PewDiePie subs are dead and it's
gone and it's gone everybody thank you
very much
this is why we can't have nice things
hey you marrying that mean review guy
no English I'm Italian sorry totally
forgot
Lemar yeah you're marrying that's me
review guy it actually works
whenever I'm hungry I just do this and
she immediately starts cooking pasta ice
not even a joke that's just truth she
makes great past I don't know what to
tell you man what do you think of my my
simply I'm joke it's a joke I love you
so much ah getting paid an everyday
struggle everybody
well now what YouTube does is that it's
all green everything I upload is green
but then you check the revenue and it's
like congratulations you made $2 thank
you I'm glad it was monetized instead of
when it's yellow this makes all the
difference for me I can look in the
camera like everyone else but am I gonna
I said it was a self timer and I said
this is a total Christian rock band shot
we should really embrace that spirit I
go for it everyone else is like hey I
can make to the mean what's feel is
looking for original content
I will never instigate violence against
my faithful audience okay but am i God
[Music]
not playing around this is a real gate
see it's real I'm level 5 Kendall story
I know how to mess you up there's photo
is from 1955 it did it was called a few
seconds before happiness 9 year olds
Brad one and two bonus me bonus meme is
dead
wake up grow up stupid 9 year olds cling
to the Past Louie is I'm coming oh my
god stop that mean stop it stop that me
I don't want to see it I don't want to
see it anymore okay it's bad enough
being Swedish okay as it is when Pierce
makes two handshakes successful
want another shake hand is when he gets
into this area where I'm like well I
don't know what you want me to do here
can we just shake hand please listen I'm
white okay I don't know how to do it
today no please no world cup means it's
too strong it hurts that too much hey
man can you show me the answer for the
fourth one yes I came but imma get it
yes this gets a solid ten out of ten let
it began but I'm a-gonna mean browsing
reddit by yourself
watching a Swedish billionaire thank you
very much browse reddit that's how its
own everybody you know why because you
have no friends
let's just keep let's just get that out
of the way okay it's alright I should
really call it what up my bros my
brothers we're best friends right
emotional manipulation for more views I
work for it works for five years guys
people still wanted me to do it it's
your own fault I don't know what this
listen I was I was always honest about
it but I am i gana I hope you guys are
enjoying this video so far if you are
make sure to leave a like and smash that
subscribe button if you're new because
we do this every single week guys I know
it's a lot of work for me to go through
these reddit's so I really do appreciate
all the support that I can possibly get
we're doing the last page if you want to
submit your meme check out a link in the
description or the ultimate glory
to put on your curriculum my meme was a
meme review I mean love why whatever
it's the same thing basically hard to
swallow pills baby pie doesn't kill
memes we just stop posting them because
we know he won't review them anymore and
we are desperate for his attention I
don't know if I agree with that I think
it's more like once you explain the joke
to so many people it kind of loses its
value unless there's more ways to play
on it I think if anything if a mean
doesn't survive meme review it's a
testimony that it probably wasn't that
great of a meme to begin with that's the
truth bub for you guys I dropped three
in a row now you guys got a hit double
subscribe for that if you want more okay
you think you're so clever huh you think
you're so smart okay fine you got me one
time one time out of 120 episodes fifty
episodes one time you got me whatever I
don't care
you're still 9 okay you're still 9 can't
believe toots killed sweet by accident
come on sleep ask it actually you know
when I tweeted out can't wait to be
surrounded by crying people here in
England as soon as Sweden lost
everyone's like this didn't H world this
didn't H world that meme only works if
you give it some time okay you're
supposed to take a meme from the past
and then something happens in the future
and then you can go they just did an H
rally
you can't go 20 minutes and then go well
it's not funny
everyone tweeted it to me and I'm like
you're not funny okay you stupid and
then yes it looks like it did age well
because England lost and I was hoping
they would win because then I could rub
it in more in the finals I want people
to suffer what's up man you're okay this
is the top meme what's up man you try to
make an earth sandwich bro I don't know
where you try to say I'm in America or
in India if we both Symon tables you put
a piece of bread on the ground
herb sandwich I think I don't understand
the game now I understand I'm ready bro
me too great that was it for this week's
li why I love this so much
this makes me genuinely happy thank you
guys for all the memes I really really
do appreciate it and thank you for
watching my videos every single day I'd
see you tomorrow good bye sleep tight my
9 year olds